eight news now prides itself with giving
back to several different organizations
that's right well this year on founders
day we added another one to our list a
non-profit ranch that uses assisted
therapy to help first responders and
veterans victoria saha gives us a look
at the work that they do using horses
horses for heroes offers a unique
approach to healing for people from all
walks of life and on this founders day 8
news now came out to see for themselves
the power these gentle giants have on
the horse human relationship
good girl good girl
20 different horses each with their own
unique personality every horse here
there's there's a connection that we get
and
you know they can feel your heartbeat
from four feet away offering tender care
to those going through a dark time
horses they do something for the soul
travis flowers was in the marine corps
for 10 years after he retired in 2013 he
found himself struggling i tried to
commit suicide twice in 2015 by hanging
it was going down that road again in
october that is when he found out about
equine assisted therapy and learning at
horses for heroes offering free sessions
to veterans and law enforcement to tell
you the truth i don't think i'd be
around you're okay director of health
and wellness libby bugle spends
countless hours helping people get
through their trauma we learn team
building skills how to focus on the
present how to be confident how to be a
leader learning about trust and respect
and boundaries finding the importance of
communicating with these one thousand
pound animals once you start to see that
fluency between the horse and the human
that makes my heart happy when the
nonprofit ranch isn't doing equine
therapy they have their hands full with
birthday parties and summer camps eight
news now volunteered to help groom bathe
and lead horses horses for heroes is
always looking for volunteers and if you
would like to contribute to help fund a
session for our veterans we have that
information up on our link at
8newsnow.com
reporting near lone mountain i'm
victoria saha this is tux live local now
cute